[Music]
welcome back to
the expert
okay all right so we have benny lou
who is a the founder and ceo of next
shark which is a leading publication for
asian american
uh news and stuff and you know what for
jk news we actually use
a lot of their articles and for many
many many many
many years so through their articles
you know what that's how you know them
that's how you know them so thanks for
being here benny
thank you for having me guys so happy to
be here seriously you know what's cool
about like a like a benny's
like um so back back back in the day
before
you were around and it was just like us
ford
maybe one other person or two i don't
know um
we were just just kidding films back
then and they had a
publication called the other asians oh
and that was just all about showcasing
like different asian talent because back
then
hollywood was like [ __ ] y'all you got
small numbers nobody wants to watch your
[ __ ]
and then benny was like oh we got to get
a website and showcase all these
asians because like everybody's talented
doing [ __ ] but like no one's really
giving them
a place for their voice and stuff
outside of youtube
so then they came and took pictures
interviewed us and there'll be like
blogs on
different kinds of artists musicians
dancers and i was like yo that shows
that's so sick man i think that was in
it too and i was like oh oh i'm not
asian they're honorary asian oh it's
before the world
and then you guys made new media rock
stars
and that was really cool actually before
then that interview we did with you guys
for the other asians that was pretty
pivotal for us because
like you guys were just making that
decision to go all in
on you know jk news i remember you
talked about how like you know you were
asking your mom to help like support you
first for a second of time because this
is what you want to do
i also remember i use i use her quote a
lot actually you said something that i
still remember to this day and it was
something along the lines of
this is like like the the most broke
i've ever felt but it's also been the
most like gratifying
you know ever so like you know that
that's like been stuck with me even to
this day
yay oh that's really cool yeah and it's
and it relates to kind of
you know the workout i do now i mean
like and you know every time i think
about
you know the work that i do and you know
whether this is worth it i keep thinking
about those words too
think about me a lot thank you benny in
that context
how did you even get into doing like
publications and wanting to
like create like an online like
newspaper or journal type of thing
you know what's interesting because like
it's funny when people ask me that
because they would think that i'm this
like really
you know crazy professional writer or
something but you know the reality is
like i was never that good of a writer i
mean i think back in
back in college i always struggled in my
writing classes um you know people
my teachers would be like hey you got to
get extra help and i think that i still
tested at like
a high school writing level did you type
like this no no my typing was good
though
like this
no it's just like you know basic grammar
issues and stuff like that like it was
just
it wasn't it was it was tough and even
in school i struggled a lot
all my writing classes from middle
school to high school and what have you
and so even so
to have like two three publications now
like it's definitely like very
interesting and i think my past writing
teachers would be like what
seriously i can see why you kind of went
that route because when i first met
you're such an inquisitive like
very curious person i remember you just
asking a bunch of questions because you
were genuinely
intrigued by whatever it is that was
like in front of you yeah no i think
that i i'm definitely an observer i mean
i think growing up um
you know i i wouldn't say that i was
like an outcast but i was just really
like you know i was really quiet i kind
of just kind of kept to myself and so i
observed a lot and
for me i'm naturally just a very curious
person i like to see
i like to see things at a bird's-eye
view of what's happening into the world
i like to look at things from you know
different perspectives
and everything and i think that um i
think a lot let's put it that way
more than i should have no i mean that's
great to your benefit right
yeah so i have some questions here from
our fans who are really curious to get
to know you better
and so the first question here is when
you started next shark
did you think it would create this big
of an impact as it has on the asian
community
no not at all and the funny thing is i
get asked about this all the time about
like the genesis of next shark and the
reality is next shark didn't start off
as an online publication targeting asian
americans
um you know i had just sold my first
company it was about fish in the sea
right
now i thought it was about
young entrepreneurs it was it was it was
about young entrepreneurs and so
um you know marine animals i know right
it's like what is this this
is like an aquatic show i was waiting
for that hammerhead shark to come out
but it never did
next try you know yeah so you know we i
was trying to figure out what to do next
uh after i sold my first company new
media rockstars as you guys were talking
about
and um you know i was just looking at
looking into what to do next and
naturally i was seeing this like rise in
you know a lot of young entrepreneurs
trying to you know do their own side
hustle start companies and everything
and i really wanted to kind of create a
publication to kind of spoke out to that
new generation
what year was this this was like 2013
later on there
yeah so you know we did it for a while
and i got i landed some great interviews
i landed uh you know one of my favorite
interviews was one of the
co-founders of apple oh [ __ ] like steve
wozniak
okay so so apple actually has three
co-founders it was like steve jobs steve
wozniak and a guy named ron wayne oh
yeah that guy the one that nobody knows
yeah so
he pulled out soon earlier or something
right yeah so what happened was like
this story is hilarious yeah he walked
into a room and then both these were
having like a philosophical argument and
then he saw and then so ron and it was
older at the time and ended up you know
solving the issue and then steve turned
around and was like okay so we're gonna
start
a company called apple you know both you
know both me and steve are gonna have
equal partnership we would like to give
you you know
uh you know equity to be our tiebreaker
if there's any disagreements between us
and so he said yes two weeks later he
sold ten percent of his shares for eight
hundred dollars
nice yeah and so you know wait not even
800 grand 800
800 at that time and so you know you
know for him like he had different
reasons i mean i can't really speak for
him because um
you know i think that for him it was
kind of a new project he had already you
know
he's like these guys are so annoying
it's not worth my time
like i don't give a [ __ ] i don't want to
deal with this [ __ ] these guys are crazy
and i remember driving dude we uh me you
know me and
you know a couple of our colleagues
mellie some of our you know my like our
close friends we
you know we drove up there we
interviewed this guy we drove all the
way to paromp which is like middle of
nowhere
in nevada park yeah we drove to perum he
actually lives in peru
oh he loves hookers huh how do you know
how do you know the city because that's
all they got is like
hookers in like a few bars he said he he
he is an lgbtq and he was actually if i
remember like one of the first like
people that come
out to steve jobs at the time and so
yeah and you know
it was it was interesting but really
cool guy i mean i just felt i felt kind
of bad from it a little bit nice guy
like we
he lives in he lives in a mobile home
and oh no yeah so like do this do you
have an iphone is it android
i have no idea actually that's a good
question though no but i remember
these fools got a samsung
yeah you know i just remember going back
to his house going to his house and
stuff and you know and he still had the
crt monitors and everything it felt like
i was stepping back through time like
you know i think the bathroom had like
back then you know in the 50s or the 60s
like carpets in the bathroom
isn't that crazy is that crazy how what
kind of foam or like not even fomo it's
like regret or like you got to deal with
so much it's like something you could
have had
i look at this guy and i'm i'm just like
you know wow like okay
so sold it you know sold ten percent of
apple stock for eight hundred dollars
how much would it be worth now like
billions i think it was like the figure
was like 50
billion to 75 billion and on top of that
another
it was like a triple whammy for them
like you know another one was that you
know
he had uh he had the original contract
between the three thieves
and i think he sold it bro this guy
makes all sorts of wrong decisions yeah
so well this is what he says he says
like i i
i you know define my life as you know
basically either
a day late or a dollar short that's just
like that's just how he defines
a human punching bag i feel so bad for
romance you're saying he was the first
guy that you ended up interviewing for
first like big interview like one of my
favorite interviews just because like
just to see this guy like go through so
much you know like having like you know
making maybe not so good decisions or
however you want to say depending on how
you want to look at it you know selling
selling his apple stock and then
ending up selling his i think he sold
his uh the original document for 700
bucks
that same document got sold i think
about a few years ago for like 1.7
million
oh my god this guy i feel so bad yeah
crazy this is this this was a movie a
biopic this would be a
crazy like i would watch this just to
see what
what is the psychology behind this what
is the psychology behind all those moves
i'm looking at him going dude you must
like have anger coming up no he's like
you know what like it is what it is and
you know i've gone through enough
already and you know i will handle it
and i'm like wow
like you got i don't know what it is you
got but you know you got some mad
patience man
this guy makes me feel good about my
life but it kind of tells you what kind
of people
steve jobs and wozniak is cause like if
i had a partner right and i see him
living in the trailer park i'm like
yo man fix yourself up here's like half
a mil just do it
and i think that maybe that's why
they're so mega successful is because
they're not as emotional
they're just like well that was the
agreement to have to be you
you know what that you know that's
interesting because like i remember i
was i think i
i need to go back to the interview but i
feel like i remember that
when i asked him hey do you feel like
you got you have to be as ruthless
as like you know someone like steve jobs
or something back then in order to
really succeed and i think that you know
his answer was like something along the
lines of yes
you know and like and that was like i
mean it's not really my style of how i
run my company
yeah me neither that's why i'm not
successful i know we care too much about
people
yeah well look at [ __ ] bezos that
[ __ ] unloaded his own stock
like that's [ __ ] wild wild man
to [ __ ] the market and buy it exactly
buy it back yeah just buy the whole
thing back you know
so maybe he's on to something maybe you
know i mean i don't i mean i
i have too much of a conscience you know
like i think about people too much
yeah all right so i have another
question for you and
it says as a high school senior did you
know if you wanted to go to college and
study or did you already know
what you wanted to do and when you did
find out what what you wanted to do and
how
like how did you end up attacking it
yeah yeah so okay i think that i didn't
answer the last question properly i
think you guys wanted to know where that
transition happened to asian content yes
right yeah yeah yeah so um so basically
it started off as
um you know a site for um you know young
entrepreneurs or people interested in
entrepreneurship and
atlanta some great interviews but i mean
about two years in we were getting some
good readership like maybe like one to
two million readers a month which wasn't
bad and we were
sounds like a lot yeah you know but i i
don't know i just felt like something
was missing i don't know what it was
like
you know i i don't even though i was
feeling fulfilled on some level i don't
know just something was missing and
number two
um you know scaling a media company is
tough you know and trying to find like
you know
good ways to monetize is kind of tough
too so we were running to some
issues on you know how do we you know
grow at that scale right
um but um as we kind of started
researching our data and everything we
noticed that our
a lot of our asian-centric content was
doing well so this is like two years in
and we just decided to try to do a
little bit more of it so every time we
feature
an asian entrepreneur or you know an
asian faith that just so happened to be
successful we just noticed like an
uptick in engagement
and um and i was getting it was weird
because like i wasn't
i wasn't trying to do it on purpose it
was just like hey you know these guys
just happen to be asian
and um it kind of goes back to your
roots with the other asians like
it's i think it just tied to what you
were saying earlier about like
i was missing something and now it's all
connecting not only is it beneficial in
the business sense but it means
something to you
yeah for sure i mean i just i never
thought that i mean the reason why the
other asians kind of fizzled out was
because we didn't think we could really
build a business out of this
i mean you know i thought that i thought
that my kind of contribution back to the
asian american community would be
you know when i become like hopefully
immensely successful and then i can give
it back to my own way whether it's like
a non-profit
and so you know basically be put in a
position where i don't i can just give
back i don't have to think about like
roi return or whatever it is i just
wanted to you know do what i do i want
it to do right
um but um yeah so and i was getting dms
at that time too of people going hey
like thank you so much for featuring
asian faces
you know we don't really you know get
that recognition in the business world
so thank you and i was actually really
surprised
by it and so i was like well you know so
i started looking deeper into it we
started showcasing more asian faces next
thing you know we started building a
bigger
audience in the asian american space and
what happened was um we kept doing more
of it we started expanding to different
verticals like food like social justice
and next thing you know like you know we
in about less than a year we became like
probably one of the leading
you know voices publications for asian
americans so
that's it congrats yeah that's so
awesome you guys should do weather in
all the
the chinatowns section chinatown dallas
chinatown miami
we were actually thinking about like
whether you know we were thinking about
hey we should do it like a weather
channel it's kind of like hey like you
know today it's going to be you know
cold so better you know go to your
nearest far restaurant or something you
know like little references or just like
think of random ideas yeah yeah so
uh i guess back to this question high
school to college then yeah as a high
school senior
you know if you wanted to go to college
and study like did you already know what
you wanted to do
did you grow up in socal i grew up in
norcal i'd grow up in norcal so you're
just already smarter than us
no no not even no you know what like it
was crazy i had
the most stereotypical like conservative
asian upbringing like literally like
when i grew up like my dad
my mom was like oh he's going to be the
best doctor literally the best doctor
lawyer ever and you know they thought
that i was going to make
strides and academics be a professor of
some sort
and then i think when i got to
kindergarten they realized that they had
to set the bar
way lower
it was so bad were you eating crayons
like what the [ __ ] what
so okay so let me let me tell you this
okay and literally like at the end of
the year like the report
the bar had been set so low for me that
at the end of the year like the
additional common part was like you know
benny has really made progress
he now knows that when the teacher is
talking he shouldn't be
making weird noises and talking and like
bothering people around him
and he'll four or five that's tight he
also know like and you know even like
during spelling tests like i didn't know
that i was supposed to you know
you go to your own corners and you would
just you know you're supposed to listen
to the teacher right i would take it out
to start drawing
on my own spelling test i get it now you
know i know right
and so yeah the bar was really low and
the sign of an entrepreneur
yeah exactly you know so literally every
year
you know in school up until middle
school was the same exact conversation
during
parent-teacher conference and it would
just be like okay i think you know
benny's really struggling i think that
we're gonna have to hold him back a
grade oh wow
yeah it was serious at the time and so
you know i
you know i got tested for adhd early on
which my parents never
you know casually didn't really mention
to me they just said i was lazy and not
like focused or whatever it is
you did test it like i didn't have hdhd
i had to take like you know additional
courses like
did they medicate you no no no no no no
no
that's that [ __ ] up so many kids yeah
yeah i'm that that's what i'm grateful
for in a sense is that you know
you know because like now that i get
older and everything too
and you know you hear about all these
things about like medication what it
could do
due to kids i'm like oh my damn this is
like this is wild you know
so how do your parents feel about you
now it's interesting i think that they
didn't really
know what i was doing until like very
recently so
no yeah it was kind of like 4 30 under
30 list even at 2018 my mom was all like
oh yeah cool but then it really she
didn't even know what you know how big
of a deal it was until
she doesn't know what forbes isn't a
forbes with her friends or she kind of
knew it but she wasn't sure how big of a
deal was oh did forbes just mention you
she like if my friends talk about it
it's huge and her friends started
talking to her about it and that's when
it started like really clicking for her
and then when
local chinese news started talking about
it then then it really really started
kicking and so
the chinese is more important than orbs
yeah exactly exactly
the chinese you know daily fortune
cookie says
it's like your parents yeah yeah it
really didn't matter what the rest of
the world was saying if it was like
until it was in their
like little circle that's when it was
like okay yes
my slime is wild so wild now and so it's
it was just like and you know what was
crazy too is that you know my my mom you
know you know how like eight like
asian parents they like compare each
other like totally that was totally like
that for my mom it would seriously be
like
like literally like i i've heard stories
like my mom telling me oh hey like this
person's parent like grabbed your
you know schedule from me and i was like
let's see how many ap tests your
your son has this year damn okay
yeah so little things like that and i
even remember like uh and i think my dad
told me something before i graduated
college right
like i remember i don't know if it was
some sort of an event or like maybe
friends getting together but like it was
basically all the moms getting together
and they're like oh you know
celebrating you know all their kids
getting into ivy leagues and my mom
having the only person whose son didn't
get into an ivy league
how much that do they have how much do
you have right and the funny thing is
now like
like some of those exact same people
that are kind of they work for you they
know they reach out to my mom now to try
to get to try to like you know talk to
me
or you know or like oh i can help my son
a certain thing so i was like
how the how the tables have turned yeah
they peeked too too early
or they're miserable because they never
found out who they were
because they their parents set a track
for them and they just had to follow it
yeah so it's not really they're too busy
spelling in the corner
yeah instead of drawing so i was late to
the show so at least like you know
there's some there's some level of
proudness coming from her now so
you know you know what i realized is
that almost
maybe i'm just attracting a lot of adhd
people because like birds of a feather
but i've noticed that a lot of uh people
who are
like tremendously successful or whatever
um they
do fall under that category and it's uh
the ability to think outside the box
and like i feel like pretty soon we're
gonna figure out a way to identify it
quicker
and help those with that same condition
to get to a place like like
in a healthy way right instead of like
we have mass education and everyone's
kind of like
in this factory and it's like hey you're
defected you're defected
but it doesn't work like that it's
really like we're different chess pieces
and it's like why are you trying to make
this [ __ ] rook
act like a night [ __ ] i think it's deep
it's interesting because like i think in
school like you know you're always like
people always teach you things but no
one ever teaches you how to learn you
know
well they're idiots it's idiots teaching
idiots really
like damn these people
sometimes they don't know how to teach
because no one taught them how to teach
really good
yeah and it's tough you know that's a
whole nother conversation with resources
giving to teachers and all that's a
whole separate like you know
monster that needs to be tackled on you
know but
yeah that's true all right next question
is what will your advice be to someone
who wants to start a business but is too
deep
in school debt wow that's a tough one i
think that
um it's like a lot of dick
i think that oh man honestly you know
it's tough i mean this this this hustle
is really really tough i mean even for
me
like you know i i had like bad business
dealings like in the past like after
college you know i've had been in debt
before i've had i've had
you know and i've had to pay that off
and you know for me
i think that um i think i took it upon
myself first like when i did have debt i
took it
upon myself to try to get out of debt as
soon as possible and i think that you
know i had a plan for myself to
you know whatever it was like you know
working jobs
as many jobs as i could to make money i
mean in college i work four jobs at once
at the same time seriously like you know
i mean i
you know all at once just so that i can
hopefully be a little bit more
financially independent don't have to
depend on the parents as much so i
always had that mindset of just like
trying to hustle and you know any way
that i could you know
make money like i'm gonna do it right
and so i think that my advice would
really just be
you know if you want to start a business
start the business but find and do
whatever you can do to you know
chip that you know balance down as much
as you can and honestly there's no real
easy way to approach it i mean i wish
there was but you know come on i was
pulling like you know more than 80 hour
weeks you know if after
you know after honestly like after you
know my day job at the time
you know after college i was i was still
like grinding it out at night sometimes
working until like two three a.m and so
it was non-stop for me
how long do you think that grind was for
man i think that
in some cases i'm still grinding even
today but i think that it's a different
grind you know yeah
at that point you're kind of like trying
to establish yourself you're trying to
you know
you're you're you're a nobody so uh you
know you don't have you don't have the
right contacts
you know you don't have the right
resources yet so you know i what i'm
trying to do is how do i make myself as
useful as possible to
you know whatever you know that could be
right and um
you know i was always on my computer
thinking of new ideas i was always like
you know trying to find little
scheming ways to make money through
internet marketing i was always trying
to land another client to
you know help manage their social media
or or whatever that is
um you know i think that uh
you know man like it's like when i when
i look back nowadays like
seeing the amount of stuff that i did i
mean crap like i i
sometimes i surprised myself like damn
like working so many you know spending
so many
hours on the grind without any sort of
um guarantee of what the next day could
look like did you pay your debt first
or did you i paid off and then you
started a business yeah i paid off
everything first and then i
and then i started a business i got out
of debt like within two years yeah and
everything and so like but you know that
it was it was hard work man you know i
um
and i think the ability to go through
that is like an important filter to
being a successful entrepreneur though
you gotta pay yourself you gotta be able
to like if
i think like for people that aren't like
someone that's asking that question like
if like if you're already in debt
how do i get into more debt and do
whatever like that's it takes someone
that
can get out of double debt and see that
vision and
push forward and go through all kinds of
[ __ ]
to be able to play in a realm where
you're like net positive you know
i'm always in debt and always out of
debt how about that
i paid my debt well i started jk
first and then i got in debt then i paid
it off
and then i went full-time jk so that's
another way too you can part-time the
business until you pay off the debt you
know who that reminds me of
donald trump you know he's like
billionaires
you know he was bankrupt like eight
times and [ __ ] times and stuff man you
know hey people
people play that game already it's okay
i feel like with entrepreneurship
that's the thing it's such a blank
canvas that there's no
right or wrong way it's the right way is
if it worked for you
yeah cause like it's kind of like what
do you call it the survival's bias right
like
like if we make it it's like of course
we think that's the answer but then
we'll find another example in the
business world where he's like no i
kept my debt but i went balls out with
my business accrued more debt
like kevin james um from uh jerky boys
movie and all that right like
he maxed out all of his [ __ ] credit
cards to go balls out for his movie
and then it made it it worked yeah but
like how many other people do that and
it didn't work
yeah it's hard yeah you only really hear
the the headlines of like you know
the good news and you know the reality
is i mean i've heard figures when i was
covering startups and entrepreneurship i
mean i've heard like
figures from like if you if you start a
startup you have
between 75 percent chance in 95 95
chance of failure yeah you think about
that you know and
um and so i feel like it's one of those
things where
you know when you look at building
companies when you look at building
startups and everything i look at it in
an analogy where you kind of have a
general feeling of where you want to go
but you don't really know the direction
exact direction you want to go so you
kind of just have to pick one and just
start going
but you have to be you know be okay
enough to
pivot and change and change directions
as soon as possible while still cutting
your losses and i think that
you know most people like you know they
they pursue something and then once if
it doesn't work out they kind of give up
or like they have like you know
like uh bad feelings about it and you
know they're like oh yeah you know this
this is not for me
or they they're stuck and they don't
even pick anything they can't
they're just like i don't even know if
it's a or b and i'm just gonna stay here
the whole time a lot of people i didn't
even realize
they don't even have dreams in the first
place so they can't even choose
the direction that they go and now that
blew my mind because i was like i
thought everyone just had something but
they were afraid to
chase it but there's a whole group of
people yeah i'm in that second group and
that's harder i think that's the
that's hard not knowing what you want
and then picking what you want and then
being afraid to pursue it that's the
next stage
pursuing it and not knowing if you can
make it that's the next stage
doing it getting paid from it but not
making a mark that's the next stage and
then i think there's
there's a couple of levels in
progression of career true i gotta admit
something that
so uh you know it's interesting because
um
because i've reached i guess you could
say some level of success of some sort i
think that there's always
[ __ ] 30 for 30. that's successful bro
like
it's okay forbes is like yeah 30 under
30. you've made it bro i don't even know
who the [ __ ] i am
it's okay you have a lot of fans don't
don't worry bart i mean i think that
um you know yeah people assume that oh
you know he's have it all figured out
and i think that people always like
throw this around like oh if you want to
be successful you got to find your
passion and you have to find your
passion and i'll admit it right here i
mean i don't know if
neck shark and what i do here is what i
want to do for the rest of my life
do i enjoy the work that i do and do i
enjoy you know what i'm giving back to
the community one thousand percent
um you know but there's still i there is
that question looming over my head it's
like you know
what is it that i really want to do when
it when all is said and done you know if
like money wasn't an issue if i didn't
have to worry about like the stresses of
the world what is that and i'm honestly
still on that journey you know how do i
want to get back what
what what do i think i want my legacy to
be so i think that the message that i
would say is that
you know like life is that journey right
you don't you're you
and sometimes like knowing where you
want to go
is that process of self-discovery and
that process of self-discovery could
take
many many many years and decades and and
i think that
too and i think that it's important to
not be stressed out if you're not there
yet i think that it's
more important to kind of remember um
you know that journey of where
uh that that beautiful journey of
getting to that destination i still
remember the day that i made the 430
under 30 list yeah i jumped up and down
i was super happy you know for about
good 10 minutes but then after that
like the rest of the day was just me
thinking about oh man like you know
all those years of working hard and and
you know being
not being recognized for your work and
you know
thinking about quitting pretty much like
every other week of some sort and to now
like you know that that's really what um
you know remain in my head after all
that time it's crazy so like for people
that
have a passion right and they they they
hit their travels and tribulations right
you know they'll like fall back on oh
this is my passion and that's kind of
like what they dig deep for
to further them in their cause right so
for you
you're saying like not necessarily next
shark is your passion
but when you do hit those trials and
tribulations with next shark
where do you dig deep down and and where
do you find that motivation to keep
pushing forward
that's a great question man i think that
i think that i always uh look at life
in terms of moving is better than not
moving and i think that
um i like to i i think that for me like
my therapy when i go through those times
i like to kind of do research i research
on you know different entrepreneurs i've
gone through a lot of trials and
tribulations i look at
you know companies that you know we're
on the brink of failure that have come
back from it
and i analyze it you know really deeply
and um and also you know and i find
solace in it to kind of see like hey
you know it's possible this can happen
and so as long as i know that there
is a chance i can turn this around i'm
going to take that chance as small as
small as it is
that's the entrepreneur of mine you know
that's the difference i think how i can
identify who's going to make it as an
entrepreneur or not
is when they see successful people they
see those examples and then they go
oh awesome they made it out of this
shitty family and they have this story
of struggle and then they freaking made
it
perfect that means i can do it versus
someone
else that sees that and they go oh but
like
that's like a two percent chance i'm not
gonna do it
and they don't see that as hope they
actually see that as like
um the opposite of hope of like yo you
have to do that much
like oh i don't know like i don't think
i can stomach that so i'm like they're
not
like discouraging instead of motivating
yeah or they blame or make excuses
of why or it's because you know this
person's like rich already or
they came from this or they'll find some
other thing right and then i'm like
so there's a difference in psychology
behind someone that's like
oh i got a two percent chance [ __ ] yeah
versus someone that's like
i have a 98 chance to fail [ __ ] that
but i do have entrepreneurial friends
that do think more cynical
and it's so weird right because i'm like
they're cynical in a lot of ways
but they still go oh my probability is
high i could do it if i that that guy's
an idiot i can do it too
yeah yeah there's two types of
entrepreneurs i think i think there's a
type that just loved the game of money
like you know they you know they're
they're serial entrepreneurs and they
they only look at the numbers kind of
like
yeah and this is what i get back you
know it's like just like chip stacking
at a poker table
yeah yeah yeah and i respect i respect
you know that if that is the way they
want to go i totally respect i think
my my my focus is that you know i i mean
of course like the money aspect is great
i mean who doesn't want to you know be
financially successful and have like
that independence but i think for me
is that you know i think that um i i'm
more
focused on you know figuring out how i
could utilize my skills in business and
everything to you know
create a product that could you know
make the community better in some way
and i don't exactly know what that is i
think that
you know we're kind of in an era where
it's like a lot of business that i see
coming out of silicon valley and a lot
of the business that i see i feel like
it's it's a lot of it it's more like you
know how do you get more and more people
addicted to this one thing you know
there isn't
i don't really see too many things about
like how can you advance society
you know in in some ways i mean even
like let's say tech how could tech be
how could tech have a positive influence
in society we were talking about
you know i was talking about an idea
with uh some friends about like hey like
you know
you know we could we could maybe create
apps to you know maybe pair like
volunteers with elderly people who need
help and stuff like that like there's so
many different aspects that you could
utilize tech for good and utilize
business for good and
you know for me in life i'm always
trying to find that equilibrium i don't
know what that equilibrium is where it's
like
i can win and everybody else around me
can win and i and
um i that that's kind of like my mantra
of how i
you know view building my companies
that's dope everyone wins
yeah i try to i mean i don't know if
it's i don't know like if some people
call me naive for thinking that way but
you know i prefer to i'm more of an
idealist show them the cover of like
30 under 30. that's all you got to say
i want to be on 30 over 30 maybe you
still got 40 on the fourth
fortune 40 under 40. man oh yeah hit me
up
the entrepreneurial person is someone
who's a problem solver though so like
regardless if you're just
um a shark that's trying to win the game
of
hacking the system and making [ __ ] ton
of dollars there's also the ones that
are like yo there's a problem in the
society and we use business
as a as a way to solve it to each his
own you know it's just the way it is
[Music]
foreign